oh my god he gets blessed the team flash
magnum's in the smoke here oh my god
magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels they're gonna get the defuse
they've done it sentinels are the
masters to reikobic champions honestly
if you're gonna hit me for this but like
obviously like n.a this and that but
like gambit is an insanely good team and
i have a feeling they're they're gonna
wipe the floor he's about to run to
sight reloading and mix one
completely whips
[Music]
[ __ ] on us i don't even care that nats
guy is unreal and when i say unreal i
mean like if gambit don't win the next
major holy [ __ ]
i don't know what they're doing wrong
chronicle the man who just destroyed
them in the prior round is just around
the school over the time i mean oh my
god
yeah he's made a meal of it it's all
going to
pieces the final moments has just shot
so brightly though blinded by the lights
gambin are the valerian masters
champions
going into valerian's second major in
berlin all eyes were on sentinels
magnum's in the smoke here oh my god
magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels they're gonna get the defuse
they've done it sentinels are the
masters to reikovic champions the
reigning kings of valor and spent the
past year dominating the north american
scene before winning the game's first
international land and they didn't just
win the tournament they won without
dropping a single game but while the
world watched them lift the trophy one
team was already plotting their coup
gambit esports gambit was formed in
september 2020 and quickly rose to being
one of the strongest teams in the cis
region and back in march of this year
they made it all the way to the
semi-finals of the emea stage 2
challengers finals players now grouping
up and ready to push him down you can
feel the tension and you can feel the
victory because fnatic have done it
they've knocked out gambit and secured
themselves a spot in iceland but even
though gamma didn't qualify for iceland
they proved that they could go
toe-to-toe with some of the best teams
in the region they [ __ ] [ __ ] on us i
don't even care that nats guy is unreal
that guy is unreal and when i say unreal
i mean like if gambit don't win the next
major holy [ __ ] i don't know what
they're doing wrong gambit wanted more
and they weren't about to let another
chance slip away gambit took down nearly
every top team in emea to earn
themselves a spot in berlin as the
number one seed from the region and when
they debuted on the international stage
they didn't disappoint
and then it just becomes a match i don't
want to watch anymore because it feels
mean
i don't worry no one's holding close
anymore flash didn't see him oh yeah
he's still here max is tucked in the
corner waiting to take the kills fisker
is going to go into oh no he's even
trying to wall back him okay that's an
ambitious play
second player spraying it's a 4k all
ready for gnats it's there just in time
to save his teammate's life to defuse
they have to go out and make sure that
it's not coming in those post time
lineups on here and a quick spray down
to close it out 13-1 back-to-back and
there is no doubt that gambit have come
to masters three on form gambit
dumpstered crazy raccoon in one of the
fastest matches ever seen on the
international stage the japanese squad
only managed two rounds across two whole
maps it was utter dominance but despite
gambit's insane performance sentinels
were still all anyone could talk about
nookie it's all falling to pieces
sentinels tearing away that just a dash
of hope that they had and now it's down
to have overall killers they know
vogue's back here he's been here every
round he's now surrounded one two three
is this just could be sick to shut him
down as kellogg's prevented the
impossible before this time six i
couldn't imagine a better player to
close it down and in flawless fashion
and after their win against g2 and a was
still on top so if gambit really wanted
to show that they were the real deal
they'd have to beat hundred thieves na's
number two team understands he goes
there ethan's going in there as well it
goes into aggressive default good for
four looking to work the ace
with the blade storm he go he's gonna
tell zepho does it my goodness the ace
to kick off the series for gambit jado
still getting pressure to zero point
hitting him as he
down as well and steel just gets dropped
dude they can't get in
like you shall not pass that's exactly
what gambit are calling out right now
there's been no windows for them to work
an absolutely dominant performance out
of game but they smack hundred thieves
around for 16 rounds or 18 whatever the
heck it was they just it was just rural
things started off strong and gambit
took their momentum into map too icebox
but just as it looked like they were
poised to take the series
everything came crashing down shadow's
good for one we go
trains one out oh just narrowly not even
against the second pitch again he's able
to get a second one heco 24 health
running for
chronicle
has plenty of health chronicle on the
tab
he's got it rose don't fake he's got to
get it to happen
he gets four he gets the red bull clutch
100 thieves we're down but they steal
the round away from gambit to push us to
map three gambit choked on icebox they
lost ten straight rounds and couldn't
close out the map and then on map three
they lost again there's nobody gonna be
playing around garage as well they're
all huddled in on the site they're
playing it tight defoe goes up top may
get a spot on the steel no steel swings
out definitely's not able to land the
shot steal does it nitro does it as well
they were down but they refused to go
quietly into that good night they take
down gambit they're going to the
knockout stage i just don't even know
what just happened we're going to watch
the game
and
it's going to be saturday we're going to
watch it but
it doesn't matter about what just
happened i guess we just stopped to
[Music]
kill them the most important thing that
we just couldn't kill them at all
they're just coming they're just kidding
us and that's the most important thing i
guess that's
that's a problem despite the humiliating
loss gambit's tournament run wasn't over
yet they still had one last chance to
qualify for the playoffs a 1v1 red car
has the res too yeah red guard has the
res he's going to be able to bring
duffel back fiscally fisker where that's
coming from he comes up top fisker has
the hind advantage oh
no
a red bull clutch a 3k and a spot in the
knockout stage for gambit
gambit's second victory over crazy
raccoon wasn't nearly as convincing as
their first both maps were pretty close
and if gambit wanted to be taken
seriously they'd need to step up their
game against vision strikers in the
quarterfinals we've already witnessed
for example when
i think it was ascend had a slow star
versus vision strikers
that was the map
they were lost before anything got going
and the thing is vision strikers also
have a lot of really cool little set
plays that they're going to be throwing
out to try and almost throw you off and
don't get me wrong i think crazy
recruits play well but they are not on
the level of a team like vision striker
so i think gambit did well but they need
to be much better and very quickly
vision strikers were a scary team they'd
already dismantled two of emea's best
squads on their way to the knockout
stage but when the quarter-finals rolled
around gambit came to play they're only
gonna be considerate of who's gonna get
the front of this it doesn't hit the
back of the site and will they be able
to work off it right it was space that
they already had shadows good for one
the rolling thunder not providing a ton
of value as max is there as well they're
entirely unfazed by that ultimate the
classic is
what have we just seen
that was not rated that was not family
friendly folks this feels like so gambit
this is such a gambit way to potentially
clean things up they try to go in buzz
gets good on one but nat who else but
gnats you've got
dropping the viper's pit
he's in a 1v4 though he drops down he
gets cleaned up chronicle gets it from
diminuendo to crescendo the gambit
symphony put together a beautiful
performance
in the end gambit was just too strong
their 2-1 win against the korean team
earned them a spot in the semi-finals
against g2 he's gonna have to push right
through it and just oh he's gonna be
spotted great angle from chronicle and
he's just buying time at this stage
shadows now coming around to play this
together they drop the pin and close it
out three kills from chronicle and 13
rounds for gambit and that's now having
to clutch this one out no idea where
mick swell is in the snake fight not
quite clearing the angle he's about to
run to sight reloading and mix well
completely whips
it out three kills five rounds there
seems to be no way for g2 to get off the
starting point looking for the cross
kellogg's tag they're losing their lives
three players remain g2
being utterly humiliated they'll get
themselves a spike one they'll give
themselves a bit of hope but shadows
looking to drop more players another one
falls it is looking all but over it's
not the kellogg's to give them anything
and g2 have been humiliated as gambit
make their way through to the final and
who the hell will doubt them now gambit
didn't just beat g2
they annihilated them their win on
icebox marked valerian's first ever 13-0
victory at an international event we
just witnessed history made here on the
masters berlin stage and it comes at the
hands of gambit and redgar yourself
how's that how does that feel to know
that you just made a statement like that
in a semi-final first ever 13-0 map
i think it's really amazing because
this team is like very important to win
them because they're from emea region
and this this winning is
i feel really amazing i didn't feel it
like when we win against like vision
strikers or crazy raccoons so right now
i'm feeling this that we are winning
right now gambit had proven themselves
as the single best team from emea they
seemed unstoppable but their record had
a black mark from their brutal loss to
100 thieves if they truly wanted to be
the best they'd have to beat n a and on
the other side of the bracket a
surprising opponent was dominating the
field
envy went through the entire group stage
without dropping a single map swept
sentinels in the quarterfinals and then
two owed hundred thieves in the semis
they looked unstoppable remember gambit
couldn't even beat hundred thieves and
envy swept them we're not really worried
about what they're doing we're gonna do
our normal prep and we're gonna go into
it with the confidence we have we just
destroyed sentinels and a hundred
thieves so we have nothing to worry
about we're gonna play our game but the
russian underdogs were ready to flip the
script on who the strongest region
really was
four on the site for envy and crash is
just watching is one that's stopped off
but it's defo how's he found that
effortless has fallen yay still says
that says victor
gambit have just butchered envy and marv
called upon in the final moments here of
this first round of ot not gonna happen
shadows 25 seconds and they gotta now
lean back towards b but red guy's still
here he still knows what's going on
there's still not to the back of the
site envy come on you've got to make
this happen chronicle he walks through
and destroys envy three back-to-back
frags and it might be four in a second
he's on the chopping block gambit have
made it to 12. chronicle the man who
just destroyed them in the prior round
is just around this corner
i mean oh my god oh yeah he's made a
meal of it it's all going to pieces
in the final moments has just shone so
brightly though blinded by the lights
gambin are the valerian masters
champions
envy played an extremely close series
but just like in iceland the grand
finals ended in a 3-0 sweep gambit truly
showed up when it mattered most it's all
about the communication it's the care in
our team yeah a lot of people watching
for nuts he's really amazing player we
can't accept we cannot not accept this
but
team play team work how we doing our job
everybody
in our team just
playing in their game
playing what they want to do playing
what they needed and this thing it's the
k why we
have that kind of performance
valerian is only a year old it's still a
new game and gambit proved that the
competition is still wide open it's
scary how good teams are getting every
single tournament we go to if you
compare the standards we've seen in this
best of uh five compared to the
reykjavik one it's just another step
even uh higher caliber
gambit's unexpected victory in berlin
goes to show that yesterday's champions
won't be on top forever no matter how
dominant they might look and going into
champions
anyone can win it all
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tech talk